watch this
yo what's up GQ it's your boy Usher
these are my essentials
watch this
well you watch this but you can't quite
see it yeah catch it
[Music]
yo this is like a bloopers day yeah this
is this is the Usher's blooper is real
now this thing has been with me for a
very long time means a lot to me it's
personal for all of my fans you know
what it does mean to me man what would I
be without the you so a little history
on the you I mean it's been you know
changing every album every cycle since
the beginning of my career it was the
first thing that was a signature of mine
it looked like this and it wasn't
blinged out like this but you know I
mean I was bottling on the budget so I
may do that you was always meant
something you know that's been tied to
me as an Entertainer I designed this you
with a jeweler out of Los Angeles
California uh Joe Rosenberg first one I
designed 100 the idea just kind of came
out of I mean I'm looking at everybody
with that chains you know mostly hip-hop
artists you know I'm saying they either
rocket Jesus pieces or crosses I was
like I want something that's assembled
of mine my you was something that I
wanted to
I wanted to brand
there you go
I roll I skate see me backwards forwards
whatever it might be sides gliding
that's what I do so I keep my skates
with me but not just any skates while
we're going to custom skates
in the South kind of customize our
sneakers you know you go out west you
know Stacy Adams should go up you know
North that's a little bit of flat
bottoms and maybe even boots you go to
Chicago they really rock boots for me I
wanted to do something that no one would
have done and let's take my Rico and
shoes that I always wear put quads on
the bottom of them and they got a little
stops sometimes I don't roll with the
stops you know if you're a pro and you
know how to really roll and you don't
need the stops but these you know I try
to keep you safe use these on stage I
use these when I'm rolling around the
world when I'm at flippers you know in
London or at a Rockefeller Center but I
put them to work yeah man
this next essential is a product of the
war I've been in and they got like what
the kind of bag is this
in this bag there are many Essentials
but this the purpose of this is to make
sure that no matter where you go you
already ready set I got lotion in here I
got a pick in here which I don't have
long hair anymore I have deodorant I got
a comb I got a brush but more than
anything what I do have that you might
not understand and know the importance
of having it is a do rag this is my
durag
this is the process of how you've tied
the do-rag
you got a kid to do right baby gotta get
to do right
oh oh
there we go
[Music]
we're straight waves be spanning baby
that's how I keep these waves popping
you know what I'm saying
[Music]
this next essential is something fairly
new I started it just you know doing the
residency in Las Vegas you know when you
go out to a bar I mean you want to make
sure you got to clean glass so why not
bring your own so I always keep mine
with me but they're not just any glasses
the bakara glasses
yeah man
I don't need a glass I'll bring my own
I like cognac you know what I'm saying
you know I like a neat so don't make me
Chase you yeah
[Music]
everybody wants to talk to somebody
that's got fresh breath but not just any
fresh breaths tridents tropical twist
fresh breath the first time I smelt this
I was like oh yeah I'm gonna kill him
with this one I tried bubble gum I've
tried you know spearmint peppermint but
you know the freshness of this and also
too I think the tropical twist is just
something different
it's like what is that you have such
fresh breaths because they try to drop a
twist
[Music]
I got a question for you where is 8701
he's at Usher's well he is Usher too
right we are at Usher's GQ shoot he's
been on a world tour but I keep him with
me everywhere we go you know he'd be
turning up I've been documenting this
Funko uh where is 8701 tour uh he's been
everywhere from Saudi Arabia you know to
the clubs in Miami Atlanta Los Angeles
he's been on private planes this dude
has actually been at Formula One races
man he's been everywhere and now we can
say he was here today I definitely
um made it a point to document all the
places and I will be sharing with you
guys if I haven't already where he has
gone and what his travels have been
8701 out
these things have always been a pleasure
to me and you should have a pair of two
my
slippers yeah yeah yo I wear these
things um whenever I'm taking a break if
I'm on a plane if I'm at the house you
know you go to people's houses you don't
want to necessarily walk around in like
shoes it's disrespectful you know my
mama raised me well so I take my shoes
off at the door and you know if I got
these and I'm cool I ain't just walking
around in my socks dirtying up my socks
you know everybody hate that you know
I'm saying just messing up your socks on
people's floors and stuff and then if
you don't have socks on if you're just
nasty like that you should have these
they come in handy so I always make sure
I got mine in my Essential bag
foreign
this is something that I picked up along
my tribals I would happen to be in
Australia and I tasted Australian
strawberry licorice not just any you
know licorice you can go get all the you
know the Twizzlers and all that stuff
but um
this right here is a delicious treat and
I always have to have it I love it you
can do like regular black liquor some
people like that you know I mean I don't
I prefer my strawberry
Australia licorice
I like sweets because this is like
ridiculous like the level of sugar in
this is just crazy but it gets me right
you know what I'm saying gets me a
little bit of what I need I need a
little pick me up you know what I'm
saying and there's not too much you know
but I do have a sweet tooth yeah
[Music]
right here it is this is my tuberose
dipty candle I like for you to you know
remember the experience that you've had
when we're together so I try to create
an essence you know what I'm saying that
just lingers when I leave it's still
there tuberose dip cheek by the way I
use many different candles but this is
one that always always works it's a bit
sexy you know what I'm saying it has
some spices in it it really lingers it
really gets in your clothes and walk
away you're like man
I feel like I was just in a Vibe I mean
when you sat in the mood you don't want
to just like have like a standard candle
you know what I'm saying like you got to
have something special so I put a little
thought into it I remember going to La
Reid's office for the first time and he
had beige dipty candles and I was like I
can't be smelling like La you know what
I'm saying so I gotta find my own you
know what I'm saying since so then I
found this one yeah there's a lot of
people that probably burned it too but I
burned it different
this essential is one that's been with
me for a long time everybody knows that
Usher wears his Shades so I always keep
a little Collective I got like a little
four pack of some of my favorite Shades
I wear shades if it's dark if it's light
you know what I'm saying it's just it's
an added accessory to my personality you
know what I'm saying it's been a part of
a lot of my looks I feel super duper you
know comfortable in my glasses but
there's different shapes you know I'm
saying you got your more modern
Square joints just real really thin and
then you want to step it up a little bit
thicken them up a little bit more just
show time right here you know you want
to go get a little frisky the blue
blocker tent you know what I'm saying I
know these ain't just standard blue
boxes these are Chrome Hearts blue
blockers you know what I'm saying and
then more
Rick Essentials you know what I'm saying
and I love my shades I wear tons and
tons of shades
I thought we were done but I got one
bonus for you this is the essential of
all Essentials a cashmere
sweatsuit man I feel like I'm completely
on the cloud it don't matter what kind
of plane I'm on or what kind of car I
mean I feel like I'm just wrapped in a
blanket this is my Rick Owens Cashmere
sweats
Gotta Love That Yo by the way I just
fall asleep wherever I'm at you know
what I'm saying when I got my you know
Dolce Gabbana the first slippers on and
my Rick Owens uh cashmere sweatsuit man
it's like I'm in a blanket literally
wherever I'm at there it is that's my
essentials GQ yeah man you watched this
peace
oh
oh is backwards
this blooper day